Traveling through the checkpoint with medications or a medical device?
Here's what you need to know to get to your destination with all you need.
Medications in liquid or solid form and paste or creams...
...in excess of 3.4 ounces are allowed in your carry-on bag.
This also goes for medical accessories...
...such as freezer packs, IV bags, pumps and syringes.
To ease the screening process,...
...make sure they are clearly labeled.
If you're traveling with a medical device that is attached to your body,...
...you will need to be sure to inform the TSA officer...
...prior to the start of your pat down.
If you can safely disconnect from your medical device...
...and that the device manufacturer allows it,...
...device can be screened via x-ray.
If you cannot disconnect from the device,...
...it may require additional screening.